[Música]
llegó la economía aquí a directo a
América de edición nocturna como siempre
Un día más con nuestra compañera Daniela
hablando en Daniela bienvenida Muchas
gracias el último día no el último día
de la semana vamos a empezar esta
Crónica de economía en Argentina porque
tiene una inflación que sigue en tres
dígitos y cada vez es más alta Así es
Rodrigo la frágil situación de este país
se ha visto agravada por una sequía
histórica desde el año pasado que ha
afectado las exportaciones de soya de
maíz y de trigo agotando a su vez las
reservas de Divisas y obstaculizando la
capacidad del gobierno para combatir la
debilidad de la moneda la inflación del
meso es superó cualquier pronóstico como
nos lo explica nuestro corresponsal en
Buenos Aires natalio
viviendo en Argentina
consumiendo bienes y servicios en el
país era difícil esperar un
comportamiento diferente de la inflación
pero este número del 8,4% de inflación
mensual Para abril no deja de ser
impactantes el más alto mensual desde
abril de 2002 más de un 108% de
inflación anual en el mes de abril
también la inflación en alimentos por
ejemplo que es clave porque afecta a los
sectores más pobres Fue de más del 10% y
todo esto además condiciona las
decisiones de los actores económicos en
un escenario de Gran incertidumbre
alimentado también por un contexto de
año electoral en el que el país elegirá
un nuevo presidente Mientras tanto el
ministro de economía Sergio massa se
espera que durante el fin de semana
anuncie medidas para contener la
inflación hay que ver qué ocurre
anteriores medidas que se han tomado no
han logrado frenar la escalada
inflacionaria veremos si en esta ocasión
las medidas que finalmente tienen efecto
bueno Daniela ayer en nuestros
informativos hablábamos sobre Twitter
porque se había anunciado que tendría
una nueva ceo pues hoy ya conocemos su
nombre ya conocemos su nombre se llaman
lenta jaccarino y viene de ser por más
de una década jefa de publicidad de mbc
Universal una figura clave en la
modernización de este negocio en la
compañía de medios y entretenimiento
allí no solamente dirigió la estrategia
publicitaria sino que fue fundamental en
el lanzamiento del servicio de
transmisión con publicidad picoc en 2020
también trabajó con Donald Trump como
miembro del Consejo presidencial de
nutrición y fitness deportivo cuando él
era presidente pues su llegada podría
ser fundamental para devolverle ingresos
publicitarios a la red social después
del Éxodo que le siguió a la compra por
parte de elon musk también es muy
cercana al Magnate De hecho hace poco lo
entrevistó en una conferencia de
publicidad en Miami y allí elogió su
ética de trabajo bueno Daniela Pues a
ver si pone un poco de orden en Twitter
después de todos los problemas que ha
habido seguramente veamos un Twitter un
poco diferente vamos a Turquía ahora
porque es uno de los temas de la semana
del domingo hay elecciones allí
cuéntanos Cómo está la economía del país
pues mire este país se enfrenta por un
lado muchísima inflación que ha causado
una crisis del costo de vida que a su
vez ha erosionado la popularidad de
regiecta y perdón después de alcanzar en
octubre pasado un máximo de 24 años hoy
está como lo vemos en alrededor del 50
por ciento anual comparable solamente
con naciones en crisis como Líbano o sri
lanka y muy por encima de otros grandes
economías del mundo como Reino Unido
zona Euro en Estados Unidos entre otro
el valor del dólar también se ha
multiplicado por 9 en la última década
esto significa que la moneda local ha
perdido casi el 95% de su precio en
términos más simples en 2013 cuando
roban fue elegido presidente cada dólar
costaba dos liras turcas hoy cuesta
alrededor de 20 liras turcas Daniela y
es que la economía está siendo un tema
central en esta campaña va a ser
decisivo en esta campaña pues estaremos
atentos el domingo de momento vamos a
hablar de McDonald's que enfrenta ahora
un juicio que podría costarle millones
pues mire esta historia un Jurado de
Florida terminó que la multinacional de
comidas rápidas y el propieta de una
franquicia suya tienen la culpa de que
un chique en magnoguette caliente de una
cajita feliz cayera sobre la pierna de
una niña de 4 años y le causara
quemaduras de segundo grado el episodio
ocurrió en 2019 la madre cuenta que
compró la comida en un daeves y la pasó
a sus hijos que estaban en el asiento
trasero después escuchó los gritos de la
niña la demanda dice que los empleados
no advirtieron a los clientes sobre la
temperatura peligrosa de la comida y que
la cocinaron a una mucho más alta de lo
necesario pero bastante alta seguramente
Daniela y que este caso Parece que ya
tiene precedentes no es la primera vez
no es la primera vez esto trajo a la
memoria colectiva una famosa demanda de
la década de 1990 en ese momento un
Jurado de Nuevo México otorgó a una
señora de 81 años 2,7 millones de
dólares en daños punitivos después de
que se quemara con el café caliente de
McDonald's que derramó sobre su regazo y
le quemó las piernas la ingle y las
nalgas
dificulta después fue reducida
drásticamente pero se concluyó que la
empresa tuvo un comportamiento abro
comillas voluntario desenfrenado e
imprudente y también insensible en este
nuevo caso de la niña de 4 años un
segundo Jurado será quien diga cuánto es
que deben pagar Estoy seguro que cuando
sepamos la cifra la tendremos aquí como
cifradía seguramente pues vamos ya con
la cifra del día pero de hoy Daniela
6,35% Esta es la tasa promedio de un
préstamo hipotecario estadounidense a 30
años y porque la traigo a colación
porque es la masa baja en más de un mes
sin embargo los compradores de vivienda
todavía se están enfrentando a un
mercado inmobiliario muy limitado por
los altos precios y también porque hay
muy pocas unidades en venta Daniela
Muchas gracias por este repaso económico
te invito a que estés con nosotros ya
con una semana en el mundo que ya llega